il tempo il tempo non esiste o quarto
d'ora per cercare di convincermi di
questo prendete due orologi
possibilmente un po migliori che queste
due vecchie patacche di mio nonno un po
più precisi
assicuratevi che siano che indichino la
stessa ora indicano la stessa ora la
stessa di questa più o meno ai 245
adesso provate alzarne 1 e abbassare
l'altro e tenerli così per un po di
tempo 12 poi rimetterli insieme di
guardare cosa indicano se gli orologi
sono un po più precisi di questi non
indicano più la stessa ora l'orologio
messo più in alto e più avanti
l'orologio messo più in basso e più
indietro
questo è un fatto ovviamente con degli
orologi come questi non è molto facile
vederlo non sono abbastanza precisi ma
oggi esistono orologi estremamente
precisi questo è un esempio questo sta
colorado e un orologio atomico adultere
uno di quelli che servono per fissare il
tempo ufficiale gli stati uniti ne
abbiamo di simili in italia firenze nei
diversi ne esistono anche versioni più
piccole commerciali sufficienti per
vedere questo questo effetto sono delle
scatolette
se voi ne prendete una la mettete in
basso non è la mettete un altro quando
li mette insieme non segnano più lo
stesso tempo il tempo passa più
rapidamente in alto e più lentamente in
basso è un fatto per esempio
immaginate di avere un fratello gemello
avete la stessa età crescita insieme
immaginate che vostro fratello va a
vivere in montagna mere stata vivere al
mare se vi incontrate dopo molto tempo
vostro fratello più vecchio e voi siete
i più giovani non sono solo gli orologi
che sono influenzati dall altezza del
campo
sono tutti fenomeni che avvengono nel
tempo l'invecchiamento la rapidità qui
pensiamo un fiore che sboccia tutto il
pendolo che oscilla il tempo passa più
veloce in alto più lentamente in basso
pensate che quando negli anni 90 inizia
gli anni 90 sono stati mandati in orbita
i primi satelliti per il gps per i
navigatori queste cose che abbiamo nelle
nostre automobili da dirci dove si amano
i fisici hanno detto agli ingegneri
attenzione perché lassù sui satelliti il
tempo passa più veloce che per
funzionare su questi satelliti non la
macchinetta centro sul serio strategica
sui satelliti c'è un orologio l'orologio
va più veloce di quello che ci si
aspetta quaggiù quindi bisognava tener
conto di questo mio ingegnere ha detto
va bene
l'intero progetto però era un progetto è
tuttora un progetto dell'esercito
americano cps gestito dall'esercito
americano quindi a capo del progetto
c'erano i generali americani e generali
americani sono generali esercito quando
mi è stato detto l'alta in prova più
lento più veloce cioè 300 tempo più
lento
non ci credo per cui i primi satelliti
sono stati mandati su con un doppio
sistema che poteva funzionare tenendo
conto non tenendo conto di questo
effetto la versione che non teneva conto
di questo effetto non funzionava il gps
non funzionerebbe assolutamente se non
si tenesse conto del fatto che era il
tempo va più veloce e così anche i
generali americani si sono dovuti
convincere che effettivamente il tempo
va più veloce su e che vuol dire vuol
dire che il tempo non è quello che ci
immaginiamo vuol dire che non possiamo
pensare a un unico tempo che scorre
uguale dappertutto qualche maniera
dobbiamo pensare che in alto in basso
più a destra più a sinistra per chi si
muove più lento perché si muove più
veloce il tempo passa velocità diversa è
come se dobbiamo cambiare la nostra
immagine del mondo da un unico goloso
che batte il tempo a tanti orologi
ognuno che era il suo e
il mondo è un covo di tutti questi
orologi e che vanno a velocità diversa
il brano è difficile se ci pensate
non è la prima volta che cambiava la
nostra immagine del mondo no hotel la
terra piatta o la terra è rotonda
questa sostanza è fermo o si sta
muovendo e ferma no sappiamo che si sta
muovendo gira intorno al sole
velocissima una rondine viene da
un'altra rondina sua mamma è una volta
che suo nonno e una volta e così via e
rondine rondine rondine io vengo da un
essere umano che figlio un altro essere
umano questo vanno quindi impossibile
che io una rondine abbiamo gli stessi
antenati in comune invece no
noi tutti abbiamo insieme quelle rondine
gli stessi antenati in comune che cos'è
che succede in tutti questi casi succede
che noi scopriamo che abbiamo delle idee
semplici naturali sul mondo che sono
sbagliate
non perché siano inadatte alla nostra
vita sono adatte alla nostra vita ma
proprio perché sono adatte alla nostra
vita si riferiscono sono buone la nostra
scala non sono più buone quando
guardiamo la vita non sulla scala di 10
o 100 1000 anni ma sulla scala di
milioni di anni o quando pensiamo a cosa
succede molto lontano
molto più oggetti che hanno molto veloci
molto piccoli molto grandi c'è un
esempio che a me sta particolarmente a
cuore
e credo sia utile per capire il tempo
che l'alto e il basso le cose cascano
dall'alto del suo basso quello e l'alto
questo è il basso è una delle strutture
fondamentali nel mondo come come lo
immaginiamo le organizziamo il mondo in
termini di alto e basso quindi
nell'universo c'è l'alto e il basso
ok direzione di versare che l'altro la
rete il basso non è proprio vero quello
che alto qui e basso a sydney
non solo ma se noi usciamo dalla terra
non c'è proprio l'altro è basso gli
astronauti li abbiamo visti nelle
immagini non si muovono la nozione di
alto e basso non c'è nell'universo non
c'è l'altro il basso dell'universo è una
lezione che vale solo qui per noi è
comoda e utile per organizzare i
fenomeni intorno a noi ma diventa
inutile insensata appena semplicemente
usciamo del nostro pianeta e andiamo
da qui alla luna come hanno fatto i
nostri astronauti in tutti questi casi
scopriamo che le nostre immagine
semplice del mondo è sbagliata e le cose
sono un po più complesse
la cosa bella è che in tutti questi casi
compreso il tempo del suggerito come il
tempo non è che adesso è facile pensare
che la terra è rotonda che fuori dalla
terra non c'è l'alto e il basso e
abbiamo visto le foto fatte dagli
astronauti dell'apollo 11 andando
andando verso la luna dalla rotonda ma
l'abbiamo capito prima l'abbiamo
qualcuno l'ha capito prima che la terra
fosse rotonda risolte che lo sapeva
si mandano da capito che nella terra una
palla che vola la terra si muove adesso
l'abbiamo vista muoversi da fuori ma
galileo e copernico lavoro ha capito
prima senza bisogno di vederla darwin e
non ha visto le specie che cambiano l'ha
capito come fare come ho fatto queste
persone a capirlo ma semplicemente
partendo da quello che si sa del mondo
osservando mettendo insieme i fatti noti
e accorgendosi che i fatti noti sono
comprensibili meglio se cambiamo
qualcosa nella nostra struttura nostra
immagine del mondo
in questa maniera tutte queste persone
sono grazie a capire qualche cosa di
nuovo cruciale su questo fatto che il
tempo va più in basso tempo va più lento
più in basso e più veloce più in alto
che oggi si osserva basta comprarsi
costano come versava logico molto
precisi e chiunque di noi può osservarlo
è stato compreso prima che fosse
osservato da einstein
cento anni fa quasi 97 anni fa nel 1915
semplicemente cercando di chiarirsi le
idee sulla fisica su quello che era
conosciuto sul mondo al suo tempo
einstein aveva da un lato la la teoria
del di newton
la grande geri e meccanica di newton
dall'altro l'elettromagnetismo
sforzandosi di trovare il modo di
combinare queste due cose che aveva una
immagine del mondo coerente ha capito
che il tempo non è una cosa che passa
uguale per tutti ma ti ci sono tanti
tempi il tempo passa velocità diversa
questo cent'anni fa oggi a riccio
succedendo la stessa cosa perché oggi
siamo di nuovo nella stessa situazione
oggi abbiamo da un lato ereditato le
bellissime teorie di einstein che nel
frattempo in 100 anni abbiamo scoperto
che funzionano benissimo li avevo
confermate abbiamo visto che ci sono i
buchi neri e cioè dall'altro lungo tutto
il ventesimo secolo è cresciuto alla
meccanica quantistica stamattina abbiamo
sentito marco a raccontarci del mondo
della fisica delle particelle tutto
fatto quello meccanico una bellissima
teoria del moto che però non combacia
bene con le teorie di einstein e con la
relatività generale
e allora la scienza cerca di rifare
ancora una volta questo tentativo di
usare quello che sappiamo per cercare di
guardare più in là nel 1960 più o meno
63 due scienziati due grandissime
scienziati americani che sono giochi da
questo signore una foto in bianco e nero
a bryce di vit
il signore della foto a colori hanno
semplicemente preso le equazioni della
relatività generale della teoria di
einstein e la meccanica quantistica e
l'hanno messa insieme hanno scritto
un'equazione un'equazione che wheeler
chiamava l'equazione de witte de with
chiamava l'equazione i will
e tutto il resto del mondo un po stufo
che va l'equazione wheeler de witte che
è questa qua no di cui non vi racconto i
dettagli
un'equazione che all'inizio ero molto
confuso non si capisce è stata molto
studiata oggi continuiamo a studiarla
oggi la teoria è voluta se riesce a
scrivere in maniera precisa e si riesce
a capire meglio quello che
significa questo è il mio lavoro questa
equazione è una caratteristica che
allora fu stupefacente lascio tutti un
po a bocca aperta
questa equazione è nata ciao mettendo
insieme quello che sappiamo sul mondo da
una parte e dall'altra a questa
caratteristica è la caratteristica
seguente tutte le equazioni se vi
ricordate qualcosa della fisica della
scuola tutte l'equazione della fisica
sono importanti fondamentali della
fisica da galileo a newton maxwell
einstein eccetera eccetera
ci dicono come cambiano le cose nel
tempo e quindi hanno tutto il tempo
dentro o la velocità cambiamenti nel
tempo c'è sempre il tempo nell'equazione
questa equazione qui non ha il tempo
dentro la variabile tempo è saltata via
scompare
e come se cercando di scrivere tutto
quello che sappiamo del mondo insieme
non c'è più il tempo che significa
questo è quello che cerco di spiegarmi
nei rimanenti quattro minuti
se mi ascoltate con attenzione spero di
riuscire a chiarirvi che cosa significa
scrivere le persone del mondo senza il
tempo non ero alla fisica più semplice
per prima cosa che studiano i ragazzi
che fanno sistema la fisica come stai
come si muove un pendolo per esempio
qualunque cosa che si muova
dobbiamo descrivere come cambia la
posizione nel tempo
quindi dobbiamo isolare la posizione e
misurare il tempo un orologio guardiamo
dove la posizione vogliamo dover
l'orologio non facciamo tabelle scheda
un'equazione che descriva come cambia
questa posizione del tempo ma qui non è
che guardiamo il tempo che guardiamo la
posizione della lancetta la lancetta si
muove e questo si muove
noi stiamo descrivendo come cambia
questa posizione quando la posizione
della lancetta cardia e ci pensate
facciamo sempre così noi che scriviamo
sempre cosa succede qualcosa in funzione
di qualcos'altro io lo dico solo che
delle cose come delle altre che si
muovono che hanno la caratteristica di
muoversi tutti insieme più o meno tutti
insieme
questo cosa vuol dire vuol dire che noi
potremmo anche fare a meno del tempo e
parlare solo di come si muove questo
pendolo in funzione di questa lancetta
io potrei dire invece che mi sono
svegliato alle 8 stamattina mi sono
svegliato nel momento in cui sono è
stata la sono venuto qui sono cominciate
a parlare nel momento in cui si sono
spente le luci eccetera
senza mai in serie a sarà il riferimento
al tempo per esempio alto e basso
no io posso dire questo sta in alto
questo sta in basso ma posso fare a meno
di dire alto e basso posso dire questo
sta verso quella luce for the lie questo
sta verso il fondo rosso sotto di me se
io sono sulla terra mi complico la vita
ma se io sono un astronauta dentro una
capsula e dico il mio amico ray anderson
passami l'orologio quello in alto non
dice quale in alto se invece gli dico
quello verso il tappeto rosso di javea
sul tappeto vostro quindi la nozione di
alto e basso sparisce perde di utilità
appena esco dalla terra bene la nozione
di tempo perde di utilità sparisce
appena esco da un ambito normale entro
nell'ambito in cui sono obbligato a
usare la gravità quantistica queste
quest'equazione qui e cos'è questo ampio
solo le cose estremamente grandi una
cosa estremamente piccole laddove ancora
non abbiamo le idee chiare sul mondo se
noi guardiamo nel estremamente piccolo a
scala estremamente estremamente piccola
e lo spazio lo spazio stesso fluttua
salta è fatto di come un mare in
tempesta
anzi lo spazio tempo addirittura questo
evento piccola come se il tempo saltasse
questi orologi che ognuno stesse una sua
cammino a una velocità diversa in ambito
piccolissimo vanno avanti indietro si
muovono eccetera
a questa scala estremamente piccola non
è più buona non serve più non funziona
più bene la nozione di tempo e quindi
noi dobbiamo siamo obbligati a ri
descrivere il mondo in termini delle
variabili una per una
senza fare riferimento al tempo è come
se avessimo da un gioco non ci vede sono
perso le lancette possiamo dire solo
come si muovono una rispetto all'altra è
un po immaginate per dare un'idea
immaginate che noi pensiamo al mondo
come un insieme di cose che si muova
quello che calde da cambiano che danzano
tutte insieme con il tempo che un
direttore d'orchestra che dà il ritmo no
12 questa immagine non funziona più del
piccolo nel piccolissimo non c'è più un
unica ritmo di tutti ed è il mondo è un
po come se fosse una danza di ogni micro
pezzo del mondo con il vicino e non
tutti insieme qual è la morale di tutta
questa storia
il tempo è un concetto utile che
organizza la nostra esperienza
quotidiana ma non è un concetto
fondamentale così come l'alto e il basso
sono concetti estremamente utili ma non
servono più appena usciamo nell'ambito
della mostra e questo vale su un sacco
di cose io credo che quello che a me
piace della scienza è questo quello che
ci insegna la scienza è che la nostra
immagine del mondo la nostra percezione
del mondo
molto spesso è sbagliata e limitata vale
solo nel nostro ambito e l'umanità
intera e come qualcuno lato nel suo
paesello dove tutti fanno la stessa cosa
poi c'è altro
si possono mangiare le altre cose
possono dire nelle altre cose si parla
di altre lingue si hanno delle altre
idee l'umanità intera esce della
piccolezza della sua pensieri e scopre
che tutto è diverso le specie si
trasformano uno dell'altro e l'alto e il
basso non sono vere il tempo non è
quella cosa lì il mondo intero è più
grande e più bello e più variegato e più
divertente di quello che ci sembra a
prima vista questa cosa un po banale
fatta di alto e basso con delle persone
più simon dagli stessi che cadono è più
ricco e per comprenderlo il sapere
antico serve poco e sapere antico tutto
il sapere antico quello che ci insegni
ai nostri padri in fondo vale solo qui
appena guardiamo un po più in là non
vale più come abbiamo sentito il primo
video stamattina universo è sterminato
noi siamo lasciamo in un angolino
piccolissimo abbiamo idee che valgono
per questo angolino piccolissima
cominciamo a guardare un pochino più in
là io credo che quello che scopriamo
ogni passo e questa è la mia conclusione
è molto più sterminato più bello più
complesso di qualunque delle idee che ci
raccontano i nostri padri
imparato da mamma e papà e questa
bellezza ci travolge questo mistero che
c'è sempre davanti a noi procediamo
passo a passo poco a poco ma che resta
sempre sconfinato ci attira ci affascina
vogliamo andarlo a vedere e per me
questa è la scienza grazie